quelle est la première chose étonnante
que mike horn fait juste après avoir
atteint le point extrême du pôle nord
est-ce qu'ils sabrent le champagne est
ce qu'il se fait une manucure est ce
qu'il appelle sa fille parce qu'il
chante à nice ados et jeunes alors comme
ça tu m'as trompé
alors mesdames et sabrer le champagne
ils sabrent le champagne très mauvaise
réponse
est oui il se fait une manucure oui
puisque mike horn se coupe les ongles
regardez où là c'est un truc de fou
ouais non mais c'est vrai et il voit là
ici voiture c'est quoi on sait jamais je
rencontre quelqu'un on
le mercure a chuté à moins 40 degrés
celsius
telle une lame de rasoir l'air
environnant est un danger permanent
y exposer n'importe quelle partie du
corps devient risqué
[Musique]
franchement on oblige les gays
et le bout de nez doit aussi commencé à
s'injecter
05 juin pagaille été dernier à molinghem
on n'a pas besoin de dix doigts non
c'est vrai qu'il n'ya messier c'est fou
est-ce que vous avez gardé des séquelles
de vos expéditions une en particulier
ou equal rumba le doigt dans accor en
perdent on perd 10 extrémités parce qu
il fait tellement froid après trois mois
sur la glace que même en mangeant douze
mille calories par jour notre corps
arrivent pas de récupérer puis les
extrémités gel pour donner en fait à
notre corps notre foi
disons qu'on devine hôpital
toute la nourriture c'est pour ça on
fait les lisent ortelli doigt les
oreilles ni ne commence que je les way à
toutes les
districts où tout ça c'est mikel hats
n'a pas perdu son lustre reprise
[Rires]
bon supporter le froid extrême mike doit
manger très gras et très riche chaque
jour comme si le manger chez ma mère ou
chez valérie bénaïm l'équivalent d'une
semaine d'alimentation d'un individu
normal 5 kg de beurre ou un menu chez
flunch à 15 euros 50 avec légumes à
volonté oui boyard bab et je vois pas
tout la réponse mais les trois heures
son nom l'abbé l'abbé n'est pas grave ou
bonheur on a du xanax qui
a donné un truc tenu un bureau sans
quelque chose de bien bonnes raisons
d'ordre est tombé l'équivalent d'une
semaine d'alimentation d'individus du
normal c'est incroyable c'est ouf par
jour
douze mille calories n'est pas vrai
ouais en fait logiquement tue c'est
cyril comme toutes d'au
moins 40 super 2000 calories en 5 heures
je sème dormant pour ckoi je pense que
de manger dormir dans le frigo
[Applaudissements]
non mais j'ai toujours ah oui et puis on
parte avec ses skis le 2-2 de poids en
trop parce que l'on mange on boit en
avant ouais tu manges en pâtira trois
mois on va en partir tu conduis points 1
et puis après tu arrives avec ses
havanes kg de moi ah ouais alors que tu
perds 30 kg ha ouais en trois mois ce
n'est que 10 kg
par mois
si tu partes
s'engraissent tu vas jamais arrivé
l'autre côté si je suis c'est impossible
ça prouve que tu veux pas tirer autant
de nourriture mais quand ce que je peux
partir là bas
heureusement que je suis la bonne
personne pour partie avec thomas